welcome to nerding out the show where we
the gamespot nerds of the office talk
about shows that we like to watch and
today we're talking about agents of
shield the Good Samaritan so let's get
into it I'm Cassidy and I'm with buddy
and Tony and we're here talking about
the Good Samaritan let's jump into it we
finally got to see ghost riders origin
story for any more as much as we can get
out of what we saw so let's talk about
that cool um so we have done like a like
a who the heck is Robby ray is a nerd it
out on this guy just on our own a bunch
I was not expecting this origin story to
be so different from the comic book
initially but then it got so far away
like like what was going on with uncle
Eli and and I just was not expecting a
dude who resembled Johnny Blaze to walk
up yeah was that Johnny boy yeah I dude
who resembled Johnny Blaze so Robbie
Rises origin story went like this he
steals a car from the place in in the
comic books he steals a car from the
place that he works maybe cuz I ruined
it yeah sure got a key was totally gonna
win the race give him back yes race ya
so in the show he pushes a car from from
from his own house is Amelie lies car
the car in the comic book his uncle's
already dead at this point and
inhabiting the car that he borrows from
his workplace that car is full of drugs
the owner of those drugs is dr. that
Sordo so baba Baba Sabo dr. Szabo
already seen in the show who's in the
show as dad Daisy's dad then he's
murdered because there's there's drugs
in the car by some weird paramilitary
group Gabe's not in the car nope so
that's the that's the differentiation
there I was not expecting his brother to
be shot in the spine and in the show and
I found it actually way better backstory
yeah then what was offered up in the
comic book Johnny Blaze shows up and
just kind of passes his mojo into Robbie
and that
how he got his powers boom it's not your
evil uncle Eli happening the body of
your car it's like this year from now
bruh cfi take this fire because it's
interesting whether or not it is Johnny
Blaze cuz it doesn't make sense in terms
of comics but what we saw in the last
episode when Lucy and Joe found a book
they were in the family home at the last
person that owned a book so was that
johnny blaze but and that's where we saw
at the carnival poster for Quentin
carnival that Johnny Blaze was a stunt
driver there's motorcycle helmets
there's like a part of a motorcycle in
that cellar so signs are pointing to
Johnny Blaze yes I I would ring road
signs I would think that I would think
they'd be hesitant to actually use
Johnny Blaze may because of the Nicolas
Cage movies or legal rights or licensing
they just added those Easter eggs so
yeah it looks like Nick apart but then
the question is so was that the devil
was that Johnny Blaze was it the spirit
of vengeance yeah wickd where did it go
and they see is Johnny Blaze free now
you said this before no spirit of
vengeance has ever passed spirit of
vengeance no yes yes no ghost rider
doesn't like it works here I'm done it's
not how any of this works dad you're hit
maybe it does me did say the thing
inside me craves vengeance says there's
something inside of them definitely
there is lenses face off yep itching
design face ah anyway so the truth about
okay Eli comes out as a bad boy very bad
boy yeah so Lucy reveals that to him
right before she kind of gets owned yeah
betrayal so reckless uncle Eli
differences here yeah uh so uncle Eli um
we were kind of we weren't upset we were
just wondering is he evil he doesn't
seem to be evil what's going on very
nice so he seems alive in this which is
very different um so they had us going
what the only the only thing is I
definitely uncle Eli is not the one
that's possessing no Robbie that's
that's out but uncle Eli becoming an
evil speed
it is still possible uncle Eli is
definitely evil yeah definitely evil
becoming an evil spirit possible there
are other spirits walking around the one
thing that they might have done is just
been like all right let's not make him a
spirit let's make some other spirits but
he's not going to be spirit let's take
that spirit thing throw it on Lucy then
we'll just burn that horrible story line
to the ground literally so that's what
happened do you think though that uncle
Eli is going to is the reason behind
like his being empowered it kind of
seems like it cuz he was trying to get
at the dark cold I mean Joe was obsessed
with the book and an e like when he
first heard about he's like where's the
spot look let's see this books and enjoy
no it's mine so it's like did he know
anything about which doesn't make sense
that he would know right now would you
so because he wanted that book right and
then at the end he won wants if he
wanted to come I god and make the Dark
Matter stuff one thing i want to say the
dark hold we're going to probably get
into this in the end but the dark hold
is owned at some point in its history by
Doctor Strange the counterpart of the
book of ashanti so really the only tie
into the movie that we can figure out
right now right how does this play into
a movie tie-in it seems like it's too
early for an origin movie yeah the try
to tie that in unless you see there's a
scene where it's sitting on a bookshelf
somewhere before just another easter egg
I just said reminder tortola side Dewey
Decimal System trail right follow the
breadcrumbs so speaking of Roxton and
isodyne we have to address that really
quickly so um momentum lab was owned by
isodyne and this was kind of a agent
Carter reference right agent Carter yeah
season two they dandy did the whole
episode storyline yeah breaching the
dark forces element from you know
another dimension doing this whole it
get got crazy and rocks on and the
comics is an evil evil evil oil
corporation they're all evil and they
might be responsible for the death of
the Starks in the comics which is
different than in movies I mean they're
just evil
okay so that was a little things like
dude they've mentioned him before last
episode yeah they're dirt rocks on sucks
basically so got it cool do I right cool
alright and where Simmons going anyone
yeah anybody anyway anyway know what
does anyone know anyone so they put a
bag over her head she has to work with
the government so we assume this has
something to do with the very end of the
last episode where mace was talking to
the senator yeah katal senator baby yeah
I don't like I don't like Jeffrey just
know my kids up to he's a butthead he
got a little like in Coulson's face were
yes like I'm the director and you lied
to me and what you know who got in his
face Brian go yeah oh noes he got
punched like 20 times but he took a lot
of hits pretty well it's pretty strong
that's a snowy don't was every mace in
the comics had no powers right Jay no
yeah he had no powers he was Patriot
than we can Captain America which was
framed physical yeah yeah he didn't
wasn't like super soldier so here he's
an inhuman all we know is he's strong
like we lift it up may yeah so he can
take a bunch of hits from ghost writer
yeah we don't know that's all we know
superpose let's get punched in the face
cool man cool awesome you're over een
and you survived so we don't have any
information on the next episode no I had
there's nothing surprisingly aren't you
thinking that it's gonna tie into dr.
strange right maybe yeah maybe we'll see
or we'll see like where is it on this
dark whole book of ashanti those are all
the fun things he plays with yeah yeah
or maybe it's another solo episode of
Simmons no man see me away oh my god I
mean conniving [ __ ] Baxter girly she
thought bubble would cuz I all he said
is it they needed her expertise on
Inhumans so that's what she's doing his
favored US government so that's where
she's taking wide a bag she I i crush on
did they wash the bag before he put it
up no they use the same bags messenger
dude can you shield got public funding
they can afford new bags that's true
well no no no they should have a logo
under then tune in next week to find out
whether or not the best
and where Simmons is going and if it's
tying into Doctor Strange and for all
your favorite TV shows comics & movie
coverage stay here with nerding out